[Music]
welcome back to Vinny tube my fellow
anime fans today the topic in hand is my
personal favorite anime from the winter
2019 mob psycho 100 yes we'll be talking
about our ultra powerful teenage ESPO
with his diligent brother a loyal ghost
and his scamming master it's quite an
amazing show where we see a lot of funny
dramatic and yes epic moments packed
throughout the series today we'll be
discussing the moments that could be
classified as the top 10 moments of the
series a word of warning though if you
haven't watched the show and planned to
or are currently watching it this video
will contain spoilers before we start
I'd like to talk about our sponsor
roster Games's new game Aurora legends
this is a Japanese adventure mobile game
on Android and iOS we're a group of
heroes fight against demons to rescue
their shattered world
the game has exquisite Japanese art
style and brings you a visual experience
like watching an anime one of the most
interesting things about this game is
that your team will automatically battle
upgrade and gather rewards while you
sleep so regardless if you're watching
anime going to school or busy or work
your heroes will still fight in advance
for you and you'll get a lot of
surprises when you log in sometimes
there are epic and legendary quests and
completing them will get rare items I'll
leave a link in the description for you
to check out
number 10 on our list is Marvel going
berserk against a roof this is one of
the first intense fights we witness as
well as one of the first times that it's
revealed that there's an unknown entity
that inhabits mob's body both Hanazawa
and mob have different ideas about how
to live their life meaningfully in clash
verbally as well as using their powers
our special moment however comes when
mob loses consciousness and awakens in
the unknown power form he literally rips
everything apart and sends everything
flying in the air including hanazawa
gotta die so we're gonna go on our coast
okay next on our list comes from the
final episode of the first season it's
the moment when Reagan uses mobs power
this is right after Reagan stops mob
from engaging in the fight with a 100%
rage he tells him that it's okay to run
away this simple line seems to free mob
as he runs away by unconsciously sending
his energy to Reagan if he was extreme
gratitude for his master for telling him
that he didn't have to fight and that he
could run mob channels 100% power which
unbelievably goes to Reagan Reagan
unaware of exactly what's happening gets
up untroubled from Sakurai's attack and
proceeds to take on the scars none of
the attacks by the enemy have any effect
on Reagan right now in a funny and
somewhat epic moment Reagan schools the
scars for their delusions and misguided
thinking even when taking on all their
attacks
[Music]
Schama good
[Music]
next on the list is mobs rage moment
this is when we were introduced to
koyama part of the upper echelon called
ska and assigned to capture mob he ends
up mistakingly targeting Ritsu attacking
him during a scuffle between middle
schools in an alley when he hurts
Ritsu despite his early attempts to try
to talk to him mob finally gets enraged
and reaches 100 percent power output at
this point and quickly shows koyama the
difference in their levels scaring him
this scene showed the bond between the
brothers and also introduced that an
organization's working in the background
[Music]
you've been lucky what's wrong there's
any physical damage suck it up next on
the list is the moment when mob
confronts Emmy and her friends unlike
most of the other moments on this list
this is a heartwarming scene instead of
an action filled one this is the moment
where mob helps Emmy realize that her
dreams are important in front of her
friends
it takes place after Emmy reveals to mob
that she only started to go out with him
because of a dare from her friends yes
unlucky protagonist thought he actually
had someone who liked him for his
courage unfortunately for him doesn't
work out like that
Emmy had recently just shared a novel
that she'd written with mob having
somewhat felt a connection with him
later when Emmy hangs out with her
friends again the leader in the group
rips her novel apart after claiming that
it's worthless
which Emmy timidly agrees to mob comes
on the scene and in his shy way
chastises the group talk about swag
it was quite refreshing from his
otherwise expressionless and passionless
presence
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next on the list is where body
improvement club and dimple face Shibata
after the hideout when Rob was resting
gets attacked Reagan and dimple tried to
figure a way out this time their enemy
is a guy who uses psychic powers to
fully enhance his physical capabilities
he's a monster that can plow through
anything
the monster following mobs body comes
across the muscle building club that
finds the unconscious mob they fight him
but can't seem to take on his strength
realizing he's intent on hurting mob the
captain protects mobs body taking all
the blows he screams how mob always
showed them courage as he kept running
on behind them how he kept fighting to
improve himself inspired them it was a
touching moment and at that crucial
point when the captain loses
consciousness dimple takes over using
the fully toned body of the captain to
its fullest capabilities dimples able to
overwhelm the enemy who is earlier
introduced as one of Klaus main fighting
units
next on the list is the crucial moment
when mobs confronted with a choice
regarding his values he and mob faces a
dilemma for the first time coming from
episode 3 of season 2 Reagan accepts a
request to accompany a group to a
haunted place to take a picture the
spirits living there are that of a
family who had died in an accident they
wish to live together for some time and
promised to depart once they feel at
peace
not exactly evil spirits you see on the
other hand Regan nonchalantly tells him
to do is since the clients are throwing
a fit but mob struggles to see if this
is actually right and freezes this is a
great scene that nicely captures the
moral dilemma of whether we're justified
in randomly deciding or has a right to
exist and what doesn't dimple who's at
the scene talks to Regan about what mobs
facing and Regan realizes that he hasn't
been paying attention to mob the world
that he sees is completely different
from the one which normal people do
quite a moving scene actually where mob
struggles and you can actually relate to
his dilemma
and number four it's the introduction of
Mogami kenji here we're introduced to
the strongest spirit mob faced till now
Mogami kenji he was a psychic who was
quite a celebrity around forty years ago
however his end was that of misfortune
his mother was cursed and darted taking
on jobs where he would kill people for
money for her medical expenses he has a
warped sense of how society functions
believing strongly that the powerful
should use their powers to dominate the
weak the group of psychics brought
before him was one of his schemes to
kill them and check if any strong
psychics exist presently unfortunately
for the psychics they're stuck with a
monster that attacks them relentlessly
mob keeps trying to use his power to
banish the spirit but realizes that this
spirit is quite strong this marked the
introduction of a new character that was
quite powerful in a really terrifyingly
awesome way each other
and number three it's shimazaki taking
on the ex car members and psychic
apprentices this is an epic and badass
MOA where shimazaki the second most
powerful member in the claw organization
faces off against the ex car members and
the apprenticed psychic members this guy
is able to see all movements and predict
his opponents moves add to this his
ability of teleportation
he's almost unstoppable if an opponent
is going to attack he preempts their
movement enabling him to either teleport
out of the way or raise his psychic
barrier it's amazing how the fight goes
down where he pretty much overpowers
multiple espers as if they're nothing in
front of him
her nasara constantly encourages
everyone once he realizes their attacks
are working despite his seeming like a
one-sided beatdown but she Misaki this
was easily one of the best animated
sequences of the entire series it was
really exciting to see as everyone
pitches in to help to defeat this
monster of an opponent
[Music]
[Music]
come on SCARA wear yukata
the second from last moment comes from
the final episode with mobs spiked with
toy tiro Suzuki aka Klaus boss the man
who plans to rule the world by himself
is an extremely powerful Espen and the
founder and leader of Klaw
the fight is pretty intense with Maude
entering 100% power output with a range
of various emotions fueling him in the
fight this leads him to enter states of
battle ecstasy which was unexpected from
someone like mob throughout the fight
Suzuki has slowly been increasing his
power output to match mobs various modes
and enters a power output range he's
never been in before though he's able to
overpower mob his body is unable to
handle all the power that he's holding
and he's about to blow up overall it was
a pretty epic battle and a great way to
wrap up the season
for classic YouTube site guys around
new similar
and finally at number one its mob versus
Mogami
this is from episode 5 which is
personally my favorite episode of the
entire series other than breathtaking
animation and direction the episode was
very important for mobs characterization
faced with overwhelming odds of the
despair and the spirits possessed by
Mogami were emitting mob struggles to
find the strength to fight he hears a
voice asking for help and it reminds him
that he was here to protect Mogami
acknowledges that mob is strong but that
he could still get stronger and has much
growing to do the fight was crazy until
the end the animation and the intensity
as well as the flow of the scenes were
amazing too overall this was a really
great moment when mob decides to use his
powers to protect out of his own
violation it captured how early a mob
would only use his power when his rage
is triggered to 100% but for the first
time he chooses to use his powers at
100% freely to protect
so which is your favorite moment from
the series comment below and let me know
don't forget to hit that like button if
you enjoyed the video and subscribe if
you haven't already also make sure to
check out our aura legends the game has
some famous voice actors from anime like
Naruto one piece and fate series there
are many heroes in this game and if you
want to improve your battle rating you
can train heroes and improve their
attributes through promoting and
awakening you can maximize your
advantage by building a combo in your
team with different hero's skills there
are exclusive rings in the game that can
increase a hero skill damage to rune set
can massively increase that's--and skill
damage build your hero with exclusive
equipment and the correct rune set will
highly increase your be our fan our
event is about to start check the
official announcement for more
information the link for the game is in
the description below that's it for
today and I'll see you next time on
Binney tube
[Music]